fat people are the last people you can
actually now make jokes about and in the
world which is sort of defined by
political correctness as the United
States and by the way Europe too has
become you have to ask the question why
are fat people the last people who are
stigmatized and the answer is none of us
including the fattest of us imagine us
to be really fat well certainly the
swine flu epidemic of 1976 became an
epidemic because we were told it was
going to become an epidemic and there's
an argument and I think a good one that
every time an epidemic is predicted it's
predicted for political rather than
epidemiological reasons that is we need
at a certain time to worry about the
world and not the politics of the world
and epidemics seem to be something
separate from politics but of course in
a global world epidemics are part of
politics well certainly in 2009 the
swine flu epidemic which we don't call
the swine flu epidemic anymore
we call it the h1n1 epidemic or in
Israel the Mexican epidemic we have seen
how politics and world politics have
shaped and anxiety going back to George
Bush as president about the potential
for an epidemic which had to be realized
you couldn't maintain people's anxiety
about avian flu and if pigs could fly
we'd have flying pigs who flew today our
fear of that mental illness is a fear of
our own instability and there isn't any
historical period none at least ones we
have historical records for in which
mental illness was not one of the most
feared aspect it was feared because all
of us think
of ourselves as potentially mentally ill
and since mental illness is the most
common form of illness that's not really
wrong certainly in the United States in
the 1960s when we began to downsize the
size of mental institutions of asylums
and deinstitutionalize people who now
live on the streets of our big cities
and our small towns one of the things we
refused to do was to acknowledge that
they are us they are part of our world
they are our sons there are our father's
there are our daughters there are
mothers I think one of the ways of
ameliorating the fear of mental illness
is to acknowledge that there we all go
at some point in our own lives
we've never kept the promise the promise
to create small comfortable secure
living units for people with mental
illness and it's a promise that would in
point of fact D sensitize us to their
presence in our societies if they live
next to us and surprise surprise were
just like us in the Middle Ages the
Catholic Church promulgated a list of
the ten deadly sins including gluttony
avarice and last year they gave us a new
list of the ten modern deadly sins and
gluttony is there and avarice has become
now part of the banking system so it
sort of disappeared but we always create
categories of excess they're not
excesses when we do them of course
they're just excesses when somebody else
does them our eating well is somebody
else's gluttony our earning a good
living is somebody else's avarice we
have sin taxes we tax those things which
at least American society in the 19th
century thought were morally bad for us
alcohol and boo
and maybe soon fatty foods and marijuana
but their sin taxes which support the
good works of society do we really want
people to stop drinking and eating fatty
foods do we want them to give up the
vices if they do who pays for our
schools one of the things that really
bothers me is the reappearance of race
as a category in medical science in
evidence-based medical science today in
the 21st century it existed in the
nineteenth century people were able to
talk about those diseases of the
african-americans that caused them to
run away from slavery they were able to
talk about the diseases of the Jews that
made it impossible for them to become
citizens in the modern world some are
another the term race has reappeared now
of course it refers to genetic cohorts
which sometimes but not always mean
groups of people who share certain
characteristics that are observable we
should be very careful about confusing
genetic cohorts with race the new study
that looks at the genetic cohorts in
sub-saharan sub-saharan Africa points
out that it is the most genetically
diverse place in the world there is no
African race there are at least forty
four of them in evidence-based medicine
starting about 20 years ago the census
categories from the US Census which
described African Americans or Hispanics
as groups became used in testing drugs
they became races which is very weird
because of course they weren't so
considered in the census every ten
years we changed these categories you
shouldn't be able to change them in
evidence-based medicine the reappearance
of race is a danger because what it does
is conflate political categories with
genetic categories and not only are they
not the same they oftentimes do not
overlap there's been a great deal of
interest and whether or not one could
diagnose and treat specific illnesses
hypertension for example in specific
groups races if you would
african-americans have a high rate of
hypertension well they're interesting
questions about that is that a problem
of a genetic cohort well the equivalent
genetic cohorts in Africa don't have
high rates of hypertension maybe it has
to do with the social position as well
as the genetic predisposition of an
individual in a group one wants to be
very careful about confusing political
categories african-americans as a
political group an economic group a
social group with a genetic cohort which
may overlap with African Americans in
the United States but not with their
ancestors and antecedents in Africa
one of the things that's so exciting
right now in the medical humanities is
the fact that we are integrating
clinical knowledge social knowledge and
cultural knowledge in order to teach
both the undergraduates who are going to
become physicians and physicians and
training the exciting thing and it's
really happening here at Emory is that
we are starting to think about all of
the knowledge the epidemiological
knowledge the genetic knowledge the
social knowledge and the cultural
knowledge in their historical
ramifications that's what's new and
that's what's hot here at Emory